a grocery store collapse causes shock in
the central part of the valley the front
part of the la bonita building near
desert in eastern just came down this
morning leaving several people hurt
they're all expected to be okay but a
lot of people are wondering how this
could have happened in the first place
sasha loptis spoke to a local expert
tonight
a horrifying collapse turns a valley
grocery store to rubble and as i'm
backing up i see the ceiling just fall
down adolfo navarate was working inside
this central valley la ponita
supermarket when its front entrance
crashed down friday sounded like a bunch
of water just falling on top of each
other stacking just
four people were hurt but things could
have been worse so we asked civil
engineer rhonda cervantes how something
like this could happen i've seen things
that have
failed before but
not to this magnitude while no official
cause is determined she says several
things could have led to what she calls
a building facade failure it could be
you know members failing but also could
be you know connections failing or
things that get weakened over time while
design flaws a saturated roof from
recent rain or the building's age could
all be contributing factors she calls an
event like this unheard of that's why
there's such
importance in all the design factors
that we as engineers have to use to make
sure that these kind of things don't
happen as for dolfo he says it's an
experience he'll never forget it's hard
to put into words because it just
happened so suddenly and he's grateful
to have walked away to tell the story
sasha loftis 8 news now
we also reached out to the property
manager of francisco center where la
bonita is located so they issued this
statement on the collapse the safety and
security of our shoppers tenants and
employees is our top priority while we
don't have details to share at this time
as to the cause of the incident we're
working closely with our tenant and
local officials in their investigation
and la bonito issued a statement on the
collapse as well saying we have more on
that actually for you on our website at
8newsnow.com